SUV TO BROOKLYN AND LIKES TO
TALK ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
DIDN'T WORK.
GOING TO COME BACK AND FIX
NEW YORK NOW.
>> I THINK THE BIG TRUTH IS
THAT HIS ABSENCE WASN'T
MISSED.
IF ANYTHING, TRAFFIC MOVED
BETTER WHEN HE IS NOT HERE.
AND THE LESSON IS BEING
MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY IS
WAY EASIER THAN IT LOOKS IF
IT DOPE CAN PHONE IT IN.
A HUGE TAX BASE.
YOU HAVE A BOTTOMLESS SUPPLY
OF TOURIST DOLLARS.
SUPERIOR POLICE AND FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
THE MAYOR SHOULD LEAVE TOWN
PERMANENTLY.
WE WILL BE FINE.
>> I JUST LIKE THE FACT THAT
IN A COUPLE YEARS PRESIDENT
TRUMP WILL STILL BE
PRESIDENT AND HE WON'T BE
MAYOR ANYMORE.
THAT IS SWEET JUSTICE.
ONE OF THE THINGS DON'T
APPRECIATE THIS PRESIDENT
FOR, JUAN, HE REALLY KNOWS
HOW TO KICK PEOPLE WHEN THEY THE
HOW TO KICK PEOPLE WHEN THEY THY
ARE DOWN.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE ALL
NEED TO REFLECT UPON AND I
JUST LOVE IT.
>> Juan: YOU KNOW WHAT?
A HIGH FIVE.
>> IT'S AN ART FORM, RIGHT?
>> Juan: ON THAT SCORE,
JESSE IS RIGHT THAT SAYS
MORE ABOUT TRUMP THAT HE IS
GOING TO KICK THIS GUY WHEN
HE IS DOWN THAN IT SAYS
ABOUT THE MAYOR.
>> Jesse: HE CAN GO BACK TO
SMOKING POT AND DROPPING
GROUNDHOGS.
THAT'S ALL HE IS GOOD FOR.
>> Juan: TRUMP CAN GO BACK
TO WHAT HE DOESN'T GO SHOW
UP FOR WORK IN THE OVAL
OFFICE BEFORE NOON.
MORE PERSONAL TIME.
HE AND DE BLASIO CAN HANG
OUT.
>> Martha: EXECUTIVE TIME.
>> Dagen: REALLY QUICK, I
HAVE A LONG MEMORY.
I APPRECIATE.
>> I WILL WAIT YEARS TO KICK
YOU WHEN YOU ARE DOWN.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
BY THE WAY HE IS LIVING,
BREATHING EXAMPLES DE BLASIO
IS OF YOU WHO SOCIALISM
FAILS.
FAILS THOSE MOST IN NEED.
OF THE DEMOCRATS NEED HIM